you
[Music]
okay so next speaker is highly from
Washington University
yeah and he's gonna talk about position
we call hi everyone my name is hi from
Washington University in San Luis this
is a jog walk with my adviser professor
Brendan Juba so the problem that we work
on is a class imbalance so we all know
that class in Balan is a situation when
one class severely out represent other
classes so some practice not claimed
that class invalid make it harder for
them for classifying imbalance data but
exist learning theory do not refer to
class imbalance so although there are
many questions and many methods that
have been proposed to correct the
imbalance variant sampling method or the
cost sensitive method but we have a
question really health so in our work
first we derived the relationship
between precision recall and accuracy
and then we claimed that the lab data
set is the only curve for class
imbalance so we proved that both
theoretically and empirically for the
related work in this problem reader at
all empirically so that every magic
except for accuracy depend on the class
imbalance average also discover the
relationship between precision Eriko and
accuracy however he didn't like
interpret relationship the consequent of
that relationship so first let's look at
our derivation for the relationship
between physician Rico and accuracy so
our theorem is support this is a
distribution of example with boolean
label and mu base positive red mu and
suppose we have a classifier H with
precision greater than point Phi then
our theorem is the Phi Epsilon epsilon
max as maximum up position and Rico
arrow then epsilon naught has to sorry
by mu epsilon ma is less or equal than
at Epsilon accuracy and less or equal
than three time mu epsilon max so in
general precision and recall is invalid
weight of accuracy scaled by the factor
of three times mu the positive rate so
the consequent of this theorem is a so
if we integrate with the VC balfe
accuracy we can conclude that with
probability at least one minus Delta at
least we need 1 over mu s landmark term
D plus 1 over the other example are
necessary and sufficient to achieve
precision and recall greater than 1
minus epsilon Mac where D is a VC
dimension of the classifier so the
present the present of the term 1 minus
1 over mu is very important because it
leads to the consequence that when the
objective is high precision and high
Rico class imbalance does impose a cost
on learning that means that in order to
achieve high prison and Rico we demand
the side of the chaining that has killed
by the imbalance so we we conclude that
using latch chaining lattice is a curved
or invalid data because it is what
concerned us in a rising arrow so let's
look at some case study when we really
need high precision because remember
when I talk about that Alethea room we
need the Samsun that precision is
greater than 0.5 so we look at some case
study when we really need high precision
so the first example is the ICU alarm
system from creating cardiac arrest so
because cardiac arrest is a very rare
event and it's very expensive so we
really want that when the system the ICU
alarm system is the patient
actually need to transfer to the ICU so
in indeed we won high precision the
another example that we
talk when the taco is a machine
translation example so in this tag we
also need really neat high precision and
Rico because you can like have high
accuracy but low Rico if you predict
rare would I never used but you can also
have like high accuracy but low
precision but in this case what the
child that you up the word in the chance
lesson may be meaningless so
brannad own has a system that's so
continuous improvement as the chaining
data increased up to like hundreds a
billion of example so it's not too clear
why he needs so much a mile data so we
did lay some investigation and we see
that we observed that most of the senton
contain rare wood and the frequency of
the rarest what in the star ascendant
will deter my the mouse data that
required to reliably chant slept
ascending so we we did an experiment on
the New York time corpus and we observed
that like at least one point five
million example are necessary to play
correctly learn like 55% of the sentence
so for the experiment part on the aim of
this experiment part is to verify our
conclusion that using last changing data
size is necessary to cope with class
imbalance so in order to do that we we
going to compare the performance of
different techniques for fixing
classroom Alan was has no modification
version but chain on a larger changing
the size so the data said that we use in
this experiment is a drug discovery data
set with about 1 million negative label
and of just like 62,000 positive label
so in the first part of the experiment
first we lay stratify the data into like
Chinese so and with about 50,000 sample
X and then we select one fo and
like we create different model by
resampling is using different layout in
violent techniques like over sampling
under sampling smooth and beef and then
we change the model using KNN for the
fuzzy rest of the data we change just
change using KN n and we repeat the
experiment 200 time and compare the
performance so you can see when you when
you do like when you just for the no
modification button when chained on a
lot data side we have significant higher
precision and Rico than the model that
use different imbalance techniques in
the second part of the experiment we
like very we compare the performance
used by different data sets I from 1100
250 to 500 thousand sample and you know
we you can see that the precision and
recall scale when the size that has had
increased in the no modification version
so to conclude we conclude that it is
not possible to achieve high precision
and recall and the severe class
imbalance unless you have like a certain
amount Atta and we cleaned up the method
for correcting class imbalance don't
have and you shouldn't just classifier
on a typical diet typical SCI data set
with high imbalance because it is very
similar to the situation that you have
low accuracy on a small data sets I so
our advice when you have to deal with
class in Vallon but you don't have
enough data our advice is to rather than
trying different technique for
correcting the imbalance you try to
explore some prior knowledge about the
domain like for example for the machine
translation example that I talked before
you can lay
child to look for the the definition of
the what in the dictionary rather than
like trying different technique for
collecting pollen that's that's all my
top thank you
[Applause]